humans have been fascinated with speed
for ages the history of human progress
is one of ever-increasing velocity and
one of the most important achievements
in this historical race was the breaking
of the sound barrier not long after the
first successful airplane flights pilots
were eager to push their planes to go
faster and faster but as they did so
increased turbulence and large forces on
the plane prevented them from
accelerating further some tried to
circumvent the problem through risky
dives often with tragic results
finally in 1947 design improvements such
as a movable horizontal stabilizer the
all-moving tail allowed an American
military pilot named Chuck Yeager to fly
the bell x-1 aircraft at 1127 km/h
becoming the first person to break the
sound barrier and travel faster than the
speed of sound the bell x-1 was the
first of many supersonic aircraft to
follow with later designs reaching
speeds over Mach 3 aircraft traveling at
supersonic speed create a shock wave
with a thunder-like noise known as a
sonic boom which can cause distress to
people and animals below or even damaged
buildings for this reason scientists
around the world have been looking at
sonic booms trying to predict their path
in the atmosphere where they will land
and how loud they will be to better
understand how scientists study sonic
booms let's start with some basics of
sound imagine throwing a small stone in
a still pond what do you see the stone
causes waves to travel in the water at
the same speed in every direction these
circles that keep growing in radius are
called wave fronts similarly even though
we cannot see it a stationary sound
source like a home stereo create sound
waves traveling outward the speed of the
waves depends on factors like the
altitude and temperature of the air they
move through
at sea level sound travels at about a
thousand 225 km/h but instead of circles
on a two-dimensional surface the wave
fronts are now concentric spheres with
the sound traveling along rays
perpendicular to these waves now imagine
a moving the sound source such as a
train as the source keeps moving in a
certain direction the successive waves
in front of it will become bunched
closer together this greater wave
frequency is the cause of the famous
Doppler effect we're approaching objects
sound higher pitched but as long as the
source is moving slower than the sound
waves themselves they will remain nested
within each other it's when an object
goes supersonic moving faster than the
sound it makes that the picture changes
dramatically as it overtakes sound waves
it has emitted while generating new ones
from its current position the waves are
forced together forming a Mach cone no
sound is heard as it approaches an
observer because the object is traveling
faster than the sound it produces only
after the object has passed will the
observer hear the sonic boom where the
Mach cone meets the ground it forms a
hyperbola leaving a trail known as the
boom carpet as it travels forward this
makes it possible to determine the area
affected by a sonic boom what about
figuring out how strong a sonic boom
will be this involves solving the famous
navier's stokes equations to find the
variation of pressure in the air due to
the supersonic aircraft flying through
it this results in the pressure
signature known as the N wave what does
this shape mean well the sonic boom
occurs when there is a sudden change in
pressure and the N wave involves two
booms one for the initial pressure rise
at the aircraft's nose and another for
when the tail passes and the pressure
suddenly returns to normal this causes a
double boom but it is usually heard as a
single boom by human years in practice
computer models using these principles
can often predict the location
and intensity of sonic booms for given
atmospheric conditions and flight
trajectories and there is ongoing
research to mitigate their effects in
the meantime supersonic flight over land
remains prohibited so our sonic booms a
recent creation not exactly while we try
to find ways to silence them a few other
animals have been using sonic booms to
their advantage the gigantic Diplodocus
may have been capable of cracking its
tail faster than sound at over 1,200
kilometers per hour possibly to deter
predators some types of shrimp can also
create a similar shock wave underwater
stunning or even killing prey at a
distance with just a snap of their
oversized claw so while we humans have
made great progress in our relentless
pursuit of speed it turns out that
nature was there first